mucho la derecha y el mundo de las
transnacionales el litro es y será de
los bolivianos
[Aplausos]
el exministro de economía luis arce
elegido por evo morales como candidato
presidencial del movimiento al
socialismo más lidera las encuestas
desde hace semanas ofrece la defensa de
la nacionalización y recuperar el
crecimiento que tenía el país antes de
la salida del ex presidente y que en su
criterio ocurrió por un golpe de estado
y la felicidad aceptó nunca en un golpe
de estado se condujo la economía durante
12 años la mayoría en un periodo de
bonanza logró superar un cáncer de riñón
y ahora busca el apoyo de los sectores
populares podemos tener un buen gobierno
de evo morales tampoco vamos a decir que
no bien a esto no se conocía antes hoy
bolivia pues pero como ha manejado un
presidente indígena entonces hemos sido
conocido bolivia
los críticos afirman que el crecimiento
fue un espejismo y que no es atribuible
a morales o arte sino a situaciones
excepcionales comparables con ganarse la
lotería dos veces las de la lotería de
las materias primas con los precios
subieron significativamente el gas
minerales y la soya que nos permitió
tener 60 mil millones de los adicionales
esos como medio plan marshall a precios
de hoy y la segunda lotería fue que
morales recibió un país sin deuda
externa prácticamente
en esta elección los bolivianos también
decidirán si vuelven a confiar en el
modelo estatista aplicado por luís arse
o si optan por otro modelo para afrontar
los graves problemas económicos y
políticos derivados de la pandemia